So I'm going to present on updates on Xanubrutinib and Senrodoclax as a treatment approach in CLL, and I'm going to try to contextualize this alongside other BTK-BCL2 doublet data.
These are my disclosures, and so I'm not going to belabor this slide again because we've presented this now a few times, but this just to highlight again that the CLL17 data demonstrated that fixed-duration therapies with VO or IV achieve similar PFS, and that progression really means different things between these arms, treatment failure with abrutinib versus potential continued clinical benefit for the fixed-duration therapies.
If you ask patients, as has been done in the VOICE survey study, not shown here, the vast majority of patients prefer all oral therapies, and a majority of patients prefer time-limited therapies.
And so there would clearly be an interest in a BTK-BCL2 doublet.
However, there's limited enthusiasm for abrutinib-based therapies, at least in the United States.
So how do the second-generation inhibitors fare in combination with venetoclax?
I'm going to highlight.
I'm going to highlight the acalabrutinib venetoclax data from the Phase III Amplify trial shown here.
In the Amplify study, patients with treatment-naive CLL in the absence of a P53 deletion or mutation were randomized to AV, AVO, or chemoimmunotherapy, demonstrating superior progression-free survival with AV over chemoimmunotherapy, leading to its recent FDA approval.
But there's some very clear questions that remain.
So first, can we extrapolate the CLL17 data?
To A plus V?
I'm not sure we can.
I think we need longer follow-up before we feel comfortable that we're seeing similar results with AV doublet.
However, this is clearly an excellent option for patients with treatment-naive CLL who require therapy, want fixed-duration therapy, are good candidates for a covalent BTK inhibitor, and strongly prefer not to receive an infusional therapy.
Also, how do P53-abarant CLL patients?
I think it's fair with this treatment.
I also think that an important feature of this regimen is that it still includes venetoclax.
And venetoclax uptake remains limited, in particular in the community setting, related to the ramp-up and STAT lab requirement.
And so there remains a need to improve feasibility.
So we really do need to address these feasibility issues and also to improve upon the safety and tolerability of BCL2 inhibitors.
And
potentially to improve upon the efficacy of BCL2 inhibitor-based therapies in CLL.
So what is the optimal ramp-up?
I would argue that probably the best ramp-up with a BCL2-based therapy is one in which we can either reduce or even potentially obviate the need for TLS laboratory monitoring, again, to make this more feasible in the community setting.
This is something that's being evaluated in the Venetian trial, which is evaluating novel venetoclax ramp-up strategies with VO or AV strategies.
What about different pharmacologic properties?
Synrhodoclax and lasaftoclax have short half-lives of 4-6 hours relative to venetoclax of 26 hours.
How might this impact on safety outcomes? How might this impact on TLS risk and potentially impact TLS mitigation strategies?
Can we improve upon the efficacy of BCL2-based therapies in CLL and other diseases?
Synrhodoclax is 14 times more pharmacologically potent than venetoclax.
Does this result in improved clinical outcomes when you give it to patients?
So, Xanubrutinib and synrhodoclax is a novel BTK-BCL2 doublet, which has been studied in treatment-naive CLL as a cohort of the BGB11417-101 phase 1 global study.
In this study, patients received 8 to 12 weeks of the Xanubrutinib lead-in at the labeled BGB11417-101 phase 1 global study.
The total dose of Xanubrutinib and synrhodoclax was 1.5 mg/dose, followed by the Xanubrutinib and synrhodoclax combination, with synrhodoclax administered at either 160 or 320 mg daily.
The total dose of Xanubrutinib and synrhodoclax administered at either 160 or 320 mg daily.
Patients had the option to discontinue therapy electively after 96 weeks of therapy or to continue until disease progression or intolerance.
137 patients were enrolled. This included 51 patients enrolled to the 160 mg dose cohort, 320 mg to the 161 mg dose cohort, and 1.5 mg to the 161 mg dose cohort.
tumor lysis syndrome, GI treatment emergent adverse events, and important toxicity for
patients on BCL-2 inhibitors are relatively uncommon and predominantly grade 1 with this
combination. Grade 3 or worse, the most common grade 3 or worse treatment emergent adverse event
was neutropenia, but this did not appear to result in increased grade 3 or worse infections,
and no fatal treatment emergent adverse events, complicated COVID-19 cases, or deaths occurred
on study. This combination demonstrated substantial efficacy in treatment-naive CLL
with high rates of UMRD-4, particularly at the 320-milligram dose, supporting the 320-milligram
dose selection for further study in the phase 3 trials. In the 320-milligram dose cohort, again,
81% were UMRD-4 at week 24, 91% at UMRD-4, which is highly encouraging, and responses appear quite
durable.
Now, of course, the million-dollar question is whether this is better than VO or AV,
and this is being addressed in two prospective randomized phase 3 trials,
including the CELESTIAL study comparing ZS with VO and the upcoming study of ZS compared with AV,
again, both in treatment-naive CLL of all risk groups.
Finally, the key question is about feasibility, right? So,
what will the final Synrhodoclax ramp-up strategy be? Will this address the feasibility issues that
have really limited Venetoclax uptake in the community to date? Thank you for your attention.